hello everyone and welcome to an
absolute bloodbath of a game and it's
from the second day of the meltwater
Champions Chester finals and it is the
uh tiebreaker game between pragnananda
and danish girin so it's the fifth game
of the match the the match was
incredibly interesting first um uh in
the first game Anisha went for some
weird sacrifice against Brock's King it
didn't work out Prague won the game very
nicely with the black pieces then Prague
also won his second game with the white
pieces uh and then uh probably needed a
draw from game three and four but a
niche won both games three and four so
it was an incredible comeback and this
is now game five so the Rapids are over
this is now Blitz and like I said it's a
bloodbath you guys will enjoy this one
uh let's dive straight into it Prague
has the white pieces and he opens with
D4
uh we have Knight to F6 a bishop to F4
G6 and Knight the C3 going for some sort
of a London system setup we have D5 E3
Bishop to G7 and now the immediate Pawn
to H4 now preparing H5 so H5 by Black
Knight to F3 we have castles and now
Queen to D2 preparing the castle Queen
Side Pawn to C5 and now uh while you
could capture you could maybe Castle
Queen side right away we have Knight the
E5 by Prague Knight the C6 and now uh
Queen side castles there is a game that
was played this year in January between
Levy Roseman and Nicolas theodoro in New
York that ended in a draw where Levy
played Bishop to B5 but here we have
castles and it is now as of move nine
that we have a completely new game so C
captures on D4 e captures and now Bishop
to F5 it's uh always uh just to go back
a little bit uh if you if you've played
against the London system I played
against the London system I I played of
the in against it in Rapid I played it
against it in classical also in Blitz
and bullet and it's always it always
feels like there's really nothing for
you to do you can always capture the C
capture Sunday for move but it just
doesn't give you all that much okay you
will develop the vegetable you will put
a rook on the semi-open C file but it's
just a very very hard to break free once
white puts the Knight on E5 but white
doesn't really have anything so as long
as you know that you know that nothing
bad can happen to you
so here C captures on D4 E Capture Sun
D4 and the chapter F5 developing the
bishop the bishop is now in a beautiful
diagonal and also the Rook can come to
C8 and here Prague needs to play F3 he
should play or he should play the sound
like prophylactic king or King B1 before
F3 and G4 the Knight is an E5 guarding
G4 so you wanna bust through the
blackings defenses we have castles on
opposite sides of the board you have to
attack the black king here but he plays
Bishop to B5 here and uh it's very
instructive how Anish uses the weird
placement of the light Square Bishop to
unleash his own attack so he plays
Knights the B4 we have Bishop to a for
now uh probably can put the uh B3 where
it will defend A2 and C2 so it's going
to be a very good Defender but a niche
doesn't allow it he plays Pawn to B5 a
beautiful Pawn sacrifice where you can
capture it or you can play Bishop to B3
but if Bishop to B3 then A5 A4 and the
attack is happening by itself so so
instead after B5 we have Bishop capture
Sun B5 and now Queen to A5 now putting
pressure on the A2 Pawn on the bishop
here and pawn to A3 by Prague now asking
Anish what do you do here and Anish
could play
a safe move he could play Rook 8 to B8
and he's just winning uh not much black
can do here if you capture on B4 just
Queen T1 check Knight the B1 you pick up
the bishop on B5 and you just continue
pushing the uh the Rooks will double and
the B file you you will advance the pawn
to E5 open up the the a file as well
there are many things you can do Knight
is coming to E4 the the queen and D2
will be attacked so this is the way to
go but Anish says uh nope I'm not
interested in material I'm gonna play
this in the style of the Old Masters and
he plays Rook F the C8 which is just a
straight out peace sacrifice so a
captures on B4 Queen to A1 with check we
have Knights the B1 and now Knight the
E4 and the reason why the line that
we've shown was the correct way for a
niche where he just uh wins on the spot
and this one is not is because now
Prague can actually defend however
defending this especially in under these
conditions so it's it's a blizzy game
you have very little time on the clock
for putting your queen on a correct
Square can be extremely difficult so
what would you play here just uh you
know just to test your how your spidey
sense is tingling uh feel free to pause
the video here and try to find the only
good move for Prague while I give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on putting the queen
to E3 and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show that is the only
square that can uh well that allows
white to survive and even a fight for
the win here as later on it will give
you access to the B3 Square which will
be a crucial Square to defend your uh
your other squares here if you play
Queen to E1 or queen to E2 you are just
lost as in the game quintet E2 was
played and now uh Anish just continues
the attack Ponte A5 we have Knight the
C6 by Pro going after the E7 Pawn this
will deliver a deadly fork or so you
would think and he just plays a captures
on B4 uh he's not interested in material
uh Knight captures on E7 with check King
to H7 and now Knight captures an F5 if
you capture the rook and see it then
Rook A2 and there's no defending the B2
Pawn so uh if you have to allow this at
least eliminate this Defender only both
of them are attacking the C2 Square so
it's hard to say which one you should
capture so Knight captures on F5 was
played now comes Rook to A2 by a niche
going after the B2 Pawn you cannot
defend it so yeah he tries uh to create
some sort of a an Escape Route for his
king queen captures on B2 King D1 now
Queen captures and B1 with check Bishop
to C1 and here on each played Rook a
captures and C2 interestingly it's it's
actually a forced mate in five for black
but they were both extremely low on time
now I'm just gonna show it for your
viewing pleasure but this Rook needs the
character and once the queen moves you
have this fancy check made of Queen
captures and C1 Queen captures Knight
captures and two on F2 with check King
to E1 and now of course The Rook
captures on C1 Rook D1 only move and
Rook captures on D1 is Checkmate as the
Knight here is defended but Anisha as he
was extremely low on time played Rook a
captures on C2 is still winning only
it's a very interesting how he does look
at its Queen to E3 Knight captures an F2
with check King to E1 and now uh you you
could play a lot of moves you could play
a rook to beat you could play Knights
the G4 you could capture the rook and H1
there are so many moves you could play
here but Anish Place Rook to E8 I mean
what what is this
he's removing the defender of the of the
rook and D3 so he could uh capture on D3
and remove the defender of one of the
bishop on C1 I mean uh absolutely every
move is winning in that position for a
niche so this one only makes it um more
spectacular so Bishop captures an E8 you
have to play this otherwise you lose
your queen now comes Knight captures and
D3 would check Queen captures on D3 and
The Rook captures on C1 we have King to
D2 defending the queen and now just
Queen captures on D3 Anish even offers
to go into the End Game King captures on
D3 and The Rook captures an H1 but it
was in this position on move 29 that
pregnant resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here your but
your knight here is hanging and once you
move the Knight You're Gonna Lose the H4
pawn and now whatever you play You're
Gonna Lose the D4 Pawn with check as
well then black has a pass D Pawn a pass
D Pawn you're just up too much material
you have four points some proc has one
and also Anisha is of the exchange he
has a rook for a night so of course the
position is completely winning for him
and the other tiebreaker game ended in
the draw which means that a niche
Against All Odds wins uh wins the match
incredible he started with with zero two
and then he won game three and four on
demand and then he won tie break so
truly truly impressive stuff by Anish
and winning it like this uh yeah
incredible stuff uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it not the
kind of Chess we were used to seeing
from a niche but always
um glad to welcome it I would like to
thank Christopher Norris mocosoft
Mikhail arboy Fernando Gibson and Harry
Barton for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event until it finishes so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day